why is it that men are having an
existential crisis around losing hair
because there has been status assigned
to still having hair that hair loss is
associated with aging with sort of I
guess weakness or fragility why is it so
many men are assigning such importance
to something that I don't even think
women can imagine if anything Jason
Statham Bruce Willis look at Nicholas
Cage in the 90s he had a Homer Simpson
level of hair on top the rock the
problem that you have is some people
suit certain hairstyles right as you've
identified the face to head ratio the
cauliflower ears all of that together
you with a shaved head is going to look
different to somebody else with a
there are tons and tons of bald men that
are hard as look at the Rock balding I
think is tied into the more manly men
and men with higher amounts of
testosterone are more inclined to board
that's why men that go on trt and big
bodybuilding dosages of steroids end up
losing their hair so if anything it's a
trait of those potentially we could
argue with Superior genetics